tag zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
wollte live euren ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen diskussion und ereignissen und
nach monatelangem warten und schlechten
nachrichten können wir endlich jetzt mal
über gute sachen reden die dritte welle
scheint gebrochen
das sagte gesundheitsminister spanier
vor wenigen tagen die institute zahlen
sinken und die ersten landkreise können
jetzt ihre maßnahmen lockern das heißt
hotels biergärten oder auch freibäder
machen jetzt wieder auf in bayern zum
beispiel betrifft das ganze 13
landkreise und kreisfreie städte dass
städte dass troy zwar viele aber andere
machen sich auch sorgen und sagen hab
das alles so eine gute idee ist wir
sollten uns nicht zu früh freuen denn in
vielen kreisen ist die lage ja auch
immer noch angespannt auch in bayern
gesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
deswegen heute vor einem politischen
überbietungswettbewerb bei den chor ohne
öffnung schritten gewarnt wie er es
nannte und sagte wörtlich wir locken
gerade bei deutlich höheren instanzen
als länder mit deutlich höherer
impfquote das darf aus der zuversicht
kein übermut werden ja und das ist immer
noch jeden treffen kann das ist heute
abend klar geworden kurz vor der sendung
kamen die eilmeldungen innenminister
horst seehofer ist positiv auf das
corona virus getestet worden und
befindet sich jetzt in häuslicher
quarantäne bislang so heißt es aus
berlin zeigt er aber keine
krankheitssymptome trotzdem die frage
kommen die lockerungen zu früh und wie
können die modellierungen uns eigentlich
helfen die waren ja auch eine großes
argument immer dafür alles dicht zu
machen und dich zu halten das besprechen
wir heute mit dem physiker und
epidemiologischen modellierer cornelius
römer und natürlich mit ihnen und euch
wie immer alles in die verführer
vorgesehenen kommentarspalten posten die
immer bitte an die netiquette halten
gute fragen gebe ich gerne weiter an
herrn römer und das ganze geht auch per
e-mail hier an dieser adresse zdf
heute.de zdf.de das wird mir dann hier
eingereicht aber vorher informiert am
römer diskutieren schalten wir nach
bayern zu meiner kollegin patricia
schäfer nach
gegen am schönen ammersee hohen nämlich
seit heute der biergarten die biergärten
wieder offen sind patricia wie sieht's
aus broich ist voll
ja daniel du das voll ist kein ausdruck
es war um 12 von so voll dass die zweite
terrasse geöffnet werden mussten mit dem
wird christoph zauner
seit wochen sind die leute gekommen
bereich seit elf uhr vormittags und auf
halb zwölf ist so richtig losgegangen
folge boden und wir haben uns kaum
retten können
ich glaube man sieht sie immer noch die
leute stehen also ich meine die tische
sehen nicht so viel aus wie sonst das
liegt einfach daran dass wir haben nicht
so viele gäste bewirten dürfen wie wir
gerne könnten ja und irgendwie ja
aufgrund der abstandsregelung aufgrund
der haushalte natürlich da ausstände
wir setzen daher richtig ein haus stand
mit kindern unter 14 jahren ohne test ja
zweihaus stände wieder mit negativen
test geimpfte natürlich brauchen keinen
testen dürfen sich sonst aber alle
müssen sich registrieren
daniel das ist auf jeden fall so und es
läuft eigentlich ist das so wie an einem
normalen sommertag im letzten jahr
eigentlich schon wenn mit den masken
nicht hätten die registrierung nicht
hätten ja gern mal auf 2009 zurück
dann wäre es eigentlich komplett normal
wunderschön und ich sage euch auch wir
stehen hier ohne maske am tag stehen am
tisch damit wir keine maske an haben
dürfen damit man weiß wo wir waren
sonst müssen wir halt hier natürlich
maskiert herumlaufen aber eben damit wir
uns ins gesicht schauen können machen
wir das hier ordentlich am tisch wie
sieht das genau nochmal ausgibt ich habe
gerade das wort testungen gehört muss
ich tatsächlich irgendwie negativen test
vorweisen um in den biergarten zu kommen
nein du brauchst kein negativen test um
in den biergarten zu kommen da reicht
die registrierung die können kann auch
hier vor ort gemacht werden wann braucht
man einen negativen tests besser sobald
sie mehr als zwei haus gewesen
also wenn man mit einer andern mit einem
anderen haus stand am tisch sitzen will
dann braucht man den negativen test
übrigens es ist alles so unberechenbar
rundum sicher noch dass ihr eine der
wenigen seite wird sich auch so
macht habe ich denke schon ja also viele
unserer kollegen lassen definitiv noch
zu weil sie einfach nicht wissen kommen
gäste ist unsicherheit ist eine
sicherheit da was brauche ich genau hier
sind einige seit zwei tagen nur am
beraten am telefon per e-mail ja um die
gäste ein geschäft oder vorzubereiten
das überhaupt zu uns kommen können
ich war auch ich bin seit heute früh um
11 da eigentlich warst du die ersten
zwei stunden nur am telefon und
zwischendurch auch immer wieder hinter
der theke am telefon
weil die leute wirklich fragen müssen
wir reservieren wie können wir kommen ja
kommt einfach vorbei bringen
patricia mitbringen wir fahren natürlich
noch nicht unter volllast ja wir haben
auch die mitarbeiter gar nichts da ja
das ist auch den kurzarbeiter ist also
mehr oder wenig ein lobt ihn in dem sinn
um die gäste zu bewirten ja wir sind
trotzdem sehr überrascht dass es dann
doch so viele leute zu uns geschafft
haben um das nicht auszukosten und
eigentlich wieder normalität zu spüren
wären wohl gerade sagen partie ist ja
seit 11 uhr im biergarten das
normalerweise kann man dann nicht mehr
reden ich bin froh dass du es kannst und
dass du da für uns die ganze zeit ist
eine frage an christoph lohnt sich das
ganze denn überhaupt oder macht er das
vor allem für das gute gefühl macht ihr
das mehrfach gute gefühl dass er wieder
da seid das ist wieder sich anfühlt wie
im richtigen leben
letzteres ja es ist ein
hoffnungsschimmer es ist das berüchtigte
licht am ende des tunnels das wieder
weitergeht für das was wir als gastgeber
eigentlich geboren sind dass wir wieder
arbeiten dürfen gäste bewirten dürfen ja
unseren unterhalt verdienen dürfen ja
aber eher weniger ja aber aufwand
dahintersteckt für diesen einen tag
jetzt schon immens gewesen mit der
produktion im vorlauf die speisen
vorzubereiten ja und morgen sollte das
wetter doch wieder etwas umschlagen ja
die nächsten zwei drei tage
wir dürfen die gäste nicht im innenraum
bewirten von dem her wird es mit der
bahn jetzt wieder schwieriger ja was
machen wir damit ja wird sonst
vielleicht kaputt gehen
das geschlecht ist das schlecht
beruhigt salat schnitzel so ist schon
ein immenser aufwand dahinter aber ihr
konntet hochfahren von letzten dienstag
habt ihr erst erfahren wenn ich etwa sie
am montag auf machen dürft am mittwoch
konnte dir anfangen vorzubereiten
richtig ist schon sehr groß aber wir
sind sehr sehr eingespielt das und sehr
gutes und langjähriges team wir kennen
das ja aufgrund david der situation und
der lage am see ist das wetter doch
umgerechnet war eigentlich ja schon
immer geht's mittel besser aber die
gäste also die die mit denen ich
gesprochen habe die sind überglücklich
vorhin hat mich ein mann angesprochen
der vor 52 jahren hier geheiratet hat er
so schön dass wir wieder kommen könnte
es am leute gesagt das ist ein
glücksmoment haben gesagt eigentlich ist
es unsere normalität aber wir wissen
kann ich wie wir uns verhalten sollen
vor lauter glück das ist wieder geht die
leute stehen auch ohne zu murren in
dieser naja sagen wir mal 50 bis 80
meter langen schlange haben muss vierte
stunde maximal dann haben wir eigentlich
den letzten gast in dreye berichtet also
das ist wirklich glaube ich schon ganz
ganz gut der welt eigentlich auch immer
super angesprochen hochzeiten sitze sehr
viele gäste heute da die eigentlich
dieses jahr bei uns heiraten wollten wir
verschieben
ja die kommen unverheiratet zu sehen ist
für uns ein tolles gefühl jetzt morgens
ist nächstes jahr aber das sind eben so
momente es geht wieder voran es geht
wieder vorwärts wir wollen wieder ich
jahre richtig es ist ja nicht der
einzige landkreis in deutschland wieder
aufmachen kann da gibt es ja noch sehr
viel weitere landkreise und wir haben
einen überblick gemacht an seinen stern
hat das gemacht für uns und zeigt mal
wieder dass jetzt abläuft mit den
lockerungen real hochfahren aufmachen
raus in den biergarten raus aus der
virus trist es in immer mehr regionen
wird das unter auflagen möglich seit
heute etwa in teilen von bayern wie hier
passau incidents unter 25 wir freuen uns
eine unheimlich es ist ein großartiges
gefühl jetzt gerade wo wir die terrasse
aufgesperrt haben sind wir alle ganz
euphorisch und freuen uns richtig dass
los geht die virus zahlen sinken in ganz
deutschland knapp 7.000 neue infektionen
in 24 stunden gut 2200 weniger als am
vergangenen montag 54 weitere todesfälle
wurden gemeldet die bundesweite sieben
tage incidents bei 119 hoffnung
zuversicht auch bei biologen der sommer
kann ganz gut werden in deutschland ich
denke dass wir zum juni hin erstmalig
wirklich effekte sehen die der impfung
zuzuschreiben sind
wir wissen nicht ganz genau ob das was
wir jetzt sehen in dieser entspannung
auch schon ein bisschen von der impfung
mitbestimmt wird wahrscheinlich nicht
wahrscheinlich ist das einfach
verhaltens bewusstsein der bevölkerung
das verhalten in der krise der wunsch
nach dem ende der antivirus
beschränkungen geduld forderte erneut
der experte wir müssen jetzt natürlich
ein bisschen aufpassen dass wir nicht zu
früh ein totale euphorie verfallen denn
wir sind einfach noch nicht so weit wie
andere länder noch nicht so weit aber
auf dem richtigen weg spürbar ab heute
zb auch in niedersachsen hier dürfen die
hotels wieder gäste empfangen erst mal
nur gäste aus niedersachsen aber
immerhin sie dürfen auf machen sie wenn
ich eure kommentare
zumindest viele die sagen lockerungen
sind schon in ordnung da wir jetzt viel
schneller impfen und jetzt auch noch der
sommer kommen zum beispiel konnten ihm
aber andere sagen auch zb härte
verspielen alles was wir uns erarbeitet
haben schade aber ich kann das auch
verstehen dass die wirtschaft in diesem
sinne die doppelte doppelten sinne die
wirtschaft am ammersee wieder anlaufen
muss patricia du bist da in amazon
gerade wieder biergarten was muss denn
passieren damit dein ganz ganz schnell
wieder zu machen muss also wir haben die
aktuelle incidents heute von 57 8 im
landkreis starnberg schon seit einer
woche ungefähr unter 100 aber christoph
wenn es wieder über 100 ist wie schnell
müsstet ihr wieder zu machen wenn es
wieder eine kritische dürfen wieder
nicht nur das ist mein aktueller
informationsstand ja das kann ganz
schnell zu ende ist ganz schnell prozent
ist die hoffnung von ganz ganz schnell
wieder zunichte gemacht was ganz klar
dass das heißt das grundgerät ein
bisschen schwierig weil unsere gast bei
einer schalte kann mich nicht hören
deswegen muss patrizier übersetzen
patricia vielen dank und ich wünsche dir
noch einen schönen abend am ammersee ich
hoffe du kannst dann tatsächlich
irgendwann mal feierabend bierchen
genehmigen und dich da hinten anstellen
und wir hoffen das ganze funktioniert
die dritte welle scheint also unter
kontrolle zu sein zumindest so halbwegs
in einigen landkreisen dabei gab es
durchaus befürchtungen dass das ganze
viel schlimmer und viel größer wird als
die zweite welle im gegen weihnachten
virologen epidemiologen und auch
modellierer haben da doch durchaus
gewarnt und haben auch mit manchem
schreckensszenario gedroht sie haben
gesagt die zahlen könnten richtig heftig
werden und jetzt ist die frage wenn man
sich das anschaut laden die
wissenschaftler innen vielleicht falsch
oder ist das was passiert ist genau das
was dann auch passieren sollte es wird
berechnet es wird gewarnt
und dann verhalten wir uns alle
dementsprechend damit es eben nicht so
kommt das besprechen wir jetzt mit dem
physiker und epidemiologischen
modellierer cornelius römer ein stück
und abend vielleicht ganz einfach mal
die erste frage was halten sie denn von
diesen lockerungsschritte die wir jetzt
gerade erleben also die lockerung
die außen in der außengastronomie die
sind eigentlich ein idealer punkt um zu
beginn einfach weil wir wissen ja alle
die ihre sohle sind der haupt
übertragungsweg mittlerweile das hat
auch die whu jetzt offiziell verkündet
und es ist so dass draußen wenn der wind
weht dann schaffen es die viren einfach
nicht sehr weit und verdünnen sich sehr
schnell deswegen ist wirklich der die
öffnung in den biergärten so der erste
wirklich gute schritt um auf dem weg
zurück zur normalität
und das ist auch das hat auch karl
lauterbach gesagt von einem monat
bereits dass wir gut drüber reden
könnten die außengastronomie bald wieder
zu öffnen und das was ich gesehen habe
jetzt in dem in der schalte war wirklich
sehr gut die man hat gesehen die leute
sind weit voneinander entfernt es ist
weht der wind durch ist es kein zelt
drüber das ist auch ganz wichtig man
sollte jetzt aufpassen dass man nicht
irgendwie so ein wintergarten gefühl
schafft sondern es muss wirklich wind
durch wen und dann ist das mit den mit
den biergärten absolut kein problem und
wir müssen einfach aufpassen dass wir
langsam genug lockern das man wirklich
schritt für schritt beobachten kann wie
sich jeder öffnungs schritt auswirkt auf
die auf das infektionsgeschehen und ja
also die biergärten sind wirklich ein
guter punkt
es unterscheidet sich ja nicht von einem
picknick im park was man da gesehen hat
vielleicht sogar ist es ist es besser
kontrolliert weil er auf dem picknick
picknick im park kontrolliert niemand
dass nicht zu viele leute aus
verschiedenen familien zusammenkommen
aber auch in peking beim picknick im
park kann man ja aufeinander hocken und
dann doch irgendwie dieses tanzen nicht
mehr einhalten dann bringt ja auch quasi
die gute frische luft nichts mehr
wenn wir aber jetzt mal kurz darauf
gucken was sie aktuell berechnen was
sagen denn ihre aktuelle modellierungen
und können sie eigentlich mit dem
geschehen was da gerade stattfindet was
wir gesehen haben im biergarten
überhaupt irgendwas kalkulieren weil es
so viele unbekannte variablen gibt was
wir gesehen haben ist ja vielleicht ist
das der grund der größte grund dafür
dass die modellierung etwas nicht
zugetroffen haben mit dem im rückblick
ist dass das verhalten der bevölkerung
das ist einfach unmöglich vorherzusagen
jetzt mit der eröffnung der biergarten
habe ich persönlich keine zu großen
sorgen weil wie gesagt das ist im
prinzip nur eine verlagerung der
aktivität vom
trainierten in die kontrollierte
atmosphäre in die kontrollierte
situation viel viel wichtiger sind so
dinge wie in gastronomie sind sachen wie
schule home office betriebe da ist
wirklich was wo wir viel kaputt machen
können wenn wir zu schnell die die
regeln zurücknehmen das heißt im
endeffekt sind das aber dann auch die
bereiche die teilweise ja ja immer noch
ganz normal genutzt werden oder wo es
auch noch große fragezeichen gibt ich
guck mal kurz hier in unsere kommentare
haben schon vorab ein paar kommentare
gesammelt da stelle ich fest tatsächlich
das ist einige gibt die natürlich sagen
dass eine gute idee zu öffnen wir können
es doch nicht ewig vor der angst
hertreiben lassen und das sagt tobias
schmidt auf youtube aber simone meint
auch irgendwann muss das normale leben
wieder losgehen denn wir weiterhin alles
zu lassen haben wir demnächst nichts
mehr zu öffnen
dagegen aber natürlich auch die anderen
meinungen zum beispiel von anneliese
schmidt die meint ja diese diskussion
hatten wir doch schon wir wissen wie es
ausgehen soll man ja nicht mindestens 50
prozent geimpft sind wird es nach hinten
losgehen und nebenbei bemerkt leben
kosten genervtes augenrollen von ihr ist
das tatsächlich so also bei wie das für
eine große rolle spielen die impfungen
und wie können sie das in ihre
berechnung mit reinnehmen dass das
allerwichtigste ist einfach dass wir uns
bewusst werden dass weiterhin menschen
sterben wir haben jetzt die fallzahlen
und gehen zwar runter aber im prinzip
ist nichts anders als damals im januar
februar als die fallzahlen auch
unterging und damals wussten wir dass
b17 kommt dass wir aufpassen müssen
jetzt ist der unterschied dass wir die
impfung haben aber der im perfekte wird
erst sagen wir in wenigen wochen monaten
anfang richtig zu wirken
und deswegen muss man einfach sehr
aufpassen dass wir können jetzt nicht
alle regeln einfach fallen lassen dafür
haben wir überhaupt nicht genug durch
impf dafür habe überhaupt nicht genug
herdenimmunität und impfung sind zwar
wichtig und das ist was uns erlaubt
jetzt schritt für schritt zu schauen was
wir locken können zum beispiel dass wir
das risiko eingehen können die
biergärten zu öffnen und zu sehen
auszuprobieren was für ein effekt das
hat aber es ist essenziell dass wir uns
weiterhin bewusst sein wissen dass das
virus ist das gleiche ist es weiterhin
genauso ansteckend wie vor einem jahr
der einzige unterschied ist dass wir ein
bisschen besser geimpft sind dass wir
vielleicht mittlerweile die regeln die
verhaltensregeln ein trainiert haben und
dass wir deswegen in bestimmten
bereichen lockern können
aber ja aber es gibt jetzt auch noch mal
ganz gezielte nachfragen zum beispiel ok
warum bleiben denn aber fitnessstudios
weiterhin geschlossen ist wir können auf
einem rechner schalten hier ist es eine
von raphael kaiser der kommentar ist
entzieht sich meinem verständnis denn es
gibt zahlreiche hygiene und test
konzepte die zahlen gehen runter die
impfungen hoch also könnte ich zusammen
fassen merkel macht die auf oder doch
nicht
also ganz kritisch es gab zum beispiel
ein sehr gut berichtet das super special
event in kanada wohnt im fitnessstudio
sich extrem viele angesteckt haben das
kann man sich auch vorstellen weil je
mehr man sich physisch getätigt um so
stärker atmen und umso mehr er solle
produziert man und gleichzeitig hat es
ist den fitnessstudios manchmal stecke
ich mein mann kommt nah miteinander in
kontakt
das letztlich sei es dass das lässt sich
doch alles irgendwie vermeiden wenn man
zum beispiel sagt man macht entweder
fitnessstudio draußen auf so ein versuch
gab es ja auch schon der ist abgebrochen
worden
man macht fitness studio mit geöffnetem
fenster man sagt irgendwie nur eine
person pro 20 quadratmeter also die
dinger sind dann quasi nur eineinviertel
so voll wie sonst wäre das nicht
zumindest auch handhabbar ich glaube die
schwierigkeit ist dass alles im detail
durch zu regeln man kann natürlich
einfach nur sagen
fitnessstudios mit einem gähnen konzept
können öffnen sondern es ist einfach
eine hochrisiko situation die zu
entschärfen ist ist extrem schwierig
auch mit einem sehr guten mit einem sehr
guten hygiene konzept ich meine klar
wenn da nur eine person im fitnessstudio
ist dann kann die machen was sie will
und es wird nicht passieren aber unter
diesen bedingungen wird kein
fitnessstudio öffnen wollen wir bewegen
uns da einem in einem konflikt der
extrem schwierig zu lösen ist und
vielleicht müssen wir einfach noch sagen
wir zwei monate warten
oder schauen wir also wenn man das
verbindet mit geimpften und genießen und
unten im hygiene konzept dann ist es was
was man sich anschauen könnte aber wir
müssen einfach extrem aufpassen dass wir
nicht zu schnell in so einem normalen
situation zurückkehren weil
dann geht es sofort wieder los mit dem
mit dem virus
das hat das mehrfach gezeigt wenn wir
nur ein bisschen nachlassen wenn
irgendwie ein bisschen stärker
übertragbare variante kommt dann dann
fängt die fälle wieder an und wir haben
momentan immer noch 200 tote am tag das
ist extrem viel ist wer viel besser wir
würden die zahlen auch und wir können
uns jetzt überlegen wollen wir jedes
weiterhin so zu sagen wir so schnell wie
möglich öffnen oder nutzen wir diese
diesen effekt den wir jetzt haben dass
wir wissen wie wir die regeln einhalten
können dass wir impfungen haben um die
fallzahlen so niedrig zu bekommen dass
die gesundheitsämter effizient
nachverfolgen können weil dann können
wir plötzlich viel mehr öffnen als
vorher
und dann bekommen wir viel mehr
sozusagen das ist wie sparen wir sparen
jetzt in dem wir jetzt weniger öffnen
und können dann später das gesparte
nutzen wenn die instanzen niedriger
wobei ist ja immer auch die beschwerden
gab wir haben zu lange gewartet wir
haben nicht hart genug zu gemacht dann
gab es modellierungen von ihnen und von
anderen die gesagt haben jetzt müssen
wir aber denn sonst haben wir hier
solche kurven das alles sehr dramatisch
aus es gibt kritik mittlerweile an
diesen rechnungen weil die so nicht
eingetreten sind wir gucken uns mal ganz
kurz an wasser so gesagt wurde den
letzten wochen und monaten
sie waren laut sie waren drastisch sie
waren vor allem pessimistisch die
warnungen vor der dritten welle im laufe
der nächsten woche über die instanz und
200 weg gehen so klar das können dann
auch 100.000 pro tag werden nach dieser
prognose wollen sich die punkten der
modellierer anschaut dann wird man echt
ein bisschen schwermütig die virologin
bringt man prognostiziert im februar der
wettlauf ist längst verloren es wird
kommen wie in england
der chef der intensivmediziner droht im
märz mit einem bergamo in deutschland am
ende kommt es glücklicherweise so
dramatisch nicht
so also das ist eigentlich eine gute
nachricht aber natürlich wirft das
fragen auf nach diesen berechnungen herr
römer sie haben sich an diesen
berechnungen mit beteiligt können sie
das mal erklären warum sie zu kurven
kommen die irgendwie durch die decke
gehen und einen monat später müssen wir
feststellen okay ist nicht so passiert
also ich kann hier erstmal nur für mich
sprechen und vielleicht versuchen zu
verstehen was was bei anderen
modellieren folgen also in meinem fall
kann man nachprüfen
das waren keine extrem situationen die
ich vorher gesagt habe alles was ich
vorher gesagt habe mit chats intervallen
ist auch ungefähr so eingetreten klar
ich lag vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen
drüber
aber das war alles immer in der schranke
die ich vorher gesagt das muss man sich
so ein bisschen vorstellen wie eine
wettervorhersage es ist ja auch so wenn
wenn ich das wetter in vier wochen
vorher sagen will dass das geht einfach
nicht genau deswegen sage ich ja es wird
vermutlich warm werden
und da wissen alle dass wenn jemand eine
wettervorhersage macht für weit in der
zukunft dann liegt die auch mal falsch
und das ist einfach extrem wichtig mit
zu kommunizieren wie groß die
unsicherheit ist und das ist was was mir
sehr wichtig war immer die die die
kompetenz intervalle anzugeben weil dann
kann man auch im nachhinein sagen klar
war kurz erklären konnte der intervalle
ist was das bedeutet im prinzip wie
genau ich wie wie groß ich denke dass
die dass das wie gut meine schätzung ist
also wenn ich zum beispiel sagen in vier
wochen könnte die inzidenz 150 sein aber
ich gehe auf aber ich glaube dass es
also aufgrund der unsicherheit auch
zwischen 100 und 200 sein könnte
dann kann man mir nach genannt nicht
vorwerfen wenn die inzidenz bei 110 war
weil ich habe gesagt ich kann mir
aufgrund der unsicherheiten in der
bevölkerung impfung und so weiter kann
ich einfach nicht genau sagen dass es
150 sein wird deswegen sage ich zwischen
100 und 200 und solange es dann in
diesem bereich eintritt ist es alles
gedeckt von von meiner vorhersage und
das ist eigentlich auch was bei vielen
modulieren passiert ist bei viva prise
man wenn man sich die anschaut im
nachhinein sie hat übrigens nie sehr
ihre modelle sehr öffentlich gemacht
habt von ihr gelesen auch auf twitter
dass sie gesagt hat grund warum sie die
modelle nicht klar also die breite
bevölkerung
initiiert hat ist weil das nie gedacht
war für die breite bevölkerung sie weil
es zu schwer zu verständlich ist sind
wir sagen wir zu wenig expertise sind
wir bisher also jetzt frei für alle sagt
sie mir zu dumm dafür oder nicht so
ungeduldig um das zu verstehen
ich hatte ich hab nichts gefühl dass
damals ist falsch verstanden wurde ich
habe nur ich habe vor allem das gefühl
dass jetzt im nachhinein bestimmte teile
der presse kommen und die modelle nehmen
die am weitesten daneben lagen also ich
es gab natürlich modelle die waren
extrem simpel holzschnittartigen wie
christian drosten vielleicht sagen würde
zum beispiel das modell des aks das habe
ich mir an dass ich hatte damals schon
bedenken als ich das gesehen habe weil
es nur einen einzigen faktor in betracht
gezogen hat und bei 117 jaja und also
von dieser modernen variante
man muss sich auch überlegen warum also
warum habe ich angefangen die modelle zu
erstellen und darüber zu berichten
man muss sich zurückdenken das war
anfang februar da ging alles schön
runter und es gab gewisse experten die
haben gesagt da ist alles super
britische mutter tante macht alles
nichts aus es wird nur verdrängen das
ist normaler prozess ja und die die die
virologen die die die sich wirklich gut
damit auskennen und epidemiologen den
war das völlig klar dass eine
übertragbare variante uns früher oder
später probleme gibt und das konnte man
vorhersehen und deswegen um das klar zu
machen um zu zeigen wir können das
vorher sagen nicht dass
ministerpräsidenten oder andere danach
sagen denn acht wochen
das konnte ja nicht vorhersagen wie das
übrigens passiert ist zum beispiel
volker bouffier hat das glaube ich so
bei einer pressekonferenz gesagt
es gab modul ihre die amis vorhergesagt
aber das kann ja jeder sagen so und
genau deswegen haben wir angefangen
diese modelle zu machen und so zu
kommunizieren und damals waren die
perfekt ihren perfekt zu getroffen und
da hat niemand von der springer presse
hat dann gesagt das ist ja super die
haben alle züge die die modellierer
hatten recht und stille nur jetzt
plötzlich als einmal natürlich die
modelle ein kleines bisschen zu hoch
waren heißt es dann ja die modellierer
haben japanische shop und es stimmt
natürlich diese das modell von von der
tu berlin das 2000 instanzen
vorhergesagt hat und srk im modell das
sehr simpel wie zu simpel
das habe ich damals schon gesagt die
lagen dann im nachhinein falsch und das
trifft aber nur auf einen kleinen teil
zu ich meine klar hat kalotte was ich
glaube ist mir gesehen im video
karl lauterbach gesagt es könnten 10.000
tote geben aber das ist ein unterschied
ob man sagt etwas ist möglich oder ob
man sagt etwas ist wahrscheinlich und
wird so eintreten okay aber das ist und
wahrscheinlich etwas was teilweise auch
in der kommunikation daneben geht dass
gibt es aber auch ich habe hier eine
wortmeldung an sie die ist sehr
dezidiert ich weiß nicht ob die jeder
versteht ich versuche sie zu verstehen
ich bin auch kein mathegenie ganz weit
weg davon
sebastian rose mann beschreibt an ihre
adresse die modellierungen von herrn
römer waren triviale fortschreibungen
ohne echtes epidemiologische modell
simple gedämpfte exponential funktionen
da kann nicht mehr jetzt schon nichts
mehr unter vorstellen also exponential
funktion weiß ich noch das ist das wo es
einfach einmal hoch geht wo ist die
epidemiologische expertise von herrn
römer möchte sebastian rose man wissen
und der wirft ihnen quasi auch
holzschnittartige modellierungen vor
jetzt gehen wir mal das risiko ein dass
einige aussteigen gedanklich aber
trotzdem möchte ich ihnen gerne mal die
gelegenheit geben darauf zu antworten
damit ins detail gehen können also ich
dass die modelle waren nie komplex ich
habe das ist auch wichtig also wenn man
gewisse sachen vorhersagen will wo große
unsicherheiten da sind zum beispiel das
verhalten der bevölkerung die die
impfrate oder den effekt von
saisonalität die die parameter die da
eingehen sind so unsicher dass man
überhaupt kein kompliziertes modell das
bringt überhaupt nichts wenn man das
über kompliziert analysiert das wichtig
der wichtigste
das wichtigste was ich gemacht habe war
die literatur zu studieren und sich
anzusehen was sind mögliche bereiche der
parameter wie schnell impfen wir
vielleicht das einzubrechen wie stark
wirkt sich saisonalität aus darauf ein
zahlenwert zu legen und dann im prinzip
die für das zu nutzen mit der
entwicklung was der vergangenheit um
dann zu sagen wie könnte es in der
zukunft liegen und natürlich dass es
keinen so komplexes modell wie das war
michael meyer hermann aber es muss es
auch gar nicht sein weil manchmal sind
einfache modelle besser weil man sie
einfacher nachvollziehen kann da kann
man dann eins in der para mi
drehen und gibt uns sofort verstehen wie
es funktioniert also ich habe nie
behauptet dass das extrem kompliziert
oder komplexe modelle sind das wichtig
ist einfach dass man dass man modelle
macht dass man vorhersagen tätig und ich
möchte noch einmal in erinnerung rufen
im februar haben wir gesagt damals ging
es runter ist wir haben gesagt es wird
mitte märz wird es wieder hoch gehen das
ist genauso ein geht also da das war
deshalb exakt zu getroffen was danach
passiert ist danach gingen die zahlen
hoch und das war eben sehr schwierig
vorherzusagen wann sie anfangen wieder
runter zu gehen und das ist eine ganz
andere situation weil das hängt extrem
stark davon ab wie die bevölkerung
reagiert das bevölkerungs verhalten ist
der grund warum wir von er gleich drei
oder vier im moment auf 1 gekommen sind
dass also ein riesen effekt und und das
kann man praktisch nicht vorhersagen ich
meine wer wer das heißt also dass wenn
man wenn man also wenn es tatsächlich so
viele parameter sind sie sagen also
verhalten der bevölkerung wie gehen wir
darauf ein saisonalität wie ist das
wetter wir sind hier draußen
wie hoch ist die ansteckungsrate von so
neue mutationen tatsächlich das ist ja
auch immer erstmal eine große
fragezeichen taugen dann solche
modellierungen überhaupt was weil es ja
wirklich doch sehr
pi mal daumen ist muss man feststellen
und das dann wenn sie sagen instituts
wert zwischen 100 und 200 liegen ja
wirklich welten dazwischen das macht ja
auch eine intensivstation wirklich
extrem viel aus auf den cds wert von 100
oder von 200 einer region haben aber sie
müssen sich vorstellen sie sind
politiker und sie müssen eine
entscheidung treffen
und dann wollen sie doch wissen in
welchen bereich können die instanzen
fallen was sind möglich ist in ein was
sind die wahrscheinlichsten szenarien
und es ist ein riesenunterschied und ich
möchte trotzdem wissen ist liegen wir
bei 10 an der institution 10 oder liegen
wir bei einer inzidenz von 100 oder 500
und es macht riesen unterschiede und
allein zu wissen dass es in einem
bestimmten bereich liegt hilft schon bei
der entscheidungsfindung und deswegen
jeder der sagt es ist einfach jeder der
sagt das bringt doch gar nichts die die
abweichungen sind zu groß der sollte es
einfach selbst machen und das kann man
ja dann im nachhinein schauen ob die
person recht hat und im prinzip ist es
zum beispiel hier sagen dass im
nachhinein kann man erst sagen ob jemand
ein guter modellierer ist oder nicht und
im fall vom rk ii wird man eben jetzt
sagen na gut also es bei rk ii hat
vielleicht nicht sozusagen die besten
modellierungs erfahrung oder in der
vergangenheit hat sie nicht die die
besten track record und andere haben
vielleicht eine bessere network und dann
wird man auch diejenigen hören die die
die richtig lagen
und ich nehme die kritik an dass ich
natürlich etwas zu hoch lag aber das ist
nichts was außerhalb dessen lag was ich
für möglich gehalten hatte da es gibt
jetzt hier kommentare das haben wir
öfter die dann mit europäischen
vergleichen kommen also sagen in
schweden zum beispiel das anders aus in
anderen europäischen ländern
ich hatte ihn gerade gesehenen kommentar
hier warum sinkt nach holland die
incidents mit öffnung und
massentourismus ist die war hoch an
liegt das ist hier so eine eine frage
gut der die frage danach dass wieder
eine verharmlosung nein cohen als keine
griffe der spitze unserer 14 seit 14
monaten unserer unser gebet quasi aber
trotzdem gibt es immer wieder die fragen
in anderen ländern hat es doch auch so
funktioniert zumindest ist das die
mutmaßung es ist ganz schwierig also ich
zum fall niederlande kann ich nicht
sagen ich kenne ich alle 180 länder die
epidemiologische situation da es ist so
dass es natürlich immer ganz stark mit
ihr kann man sagen es hängt ganz stark
vom vater der bevölkerung vor ort ab es
hängt ganz stark von den regeln vor ort
ab und zwar kann man die nicht pauschal
vergleichen zum beispiel ist es so dass
in der schweiz extrem hat es hatte home
office regeln gelten viel stärker als in
deutschland
das ist wirklich verpflichtend so wie es
jetzt in deutschland vielleicht erst mit
der zeit kamen dafür ist in der schweiz
vielmehr offen
schon viel länger und das ist ganz
schwierig man kann gar nicht so richtig
sagen was da jetzt der ausschlaggebende
faktor ist und inwiefern sich die als
kultur fans sind ja auch unterschiedlich
vielleicht halten sich die die
niederländische bevölkerung wer hätte
sich besser an die geltenden regeln oder
vielleicht leben in niederlanden einfach
die menschen in klaren haushalten bis
zum beispiel in schweden so dass da die
die geringste über die höchste ein
einzelpersonen haushalts dichte ist auf
der welt und so sachen dass das ist ganz
schwierig das zu vergleichen
das gleiche hatten wir ich erinnere mich
das gleiche hat mir damals mit portugal
und großbritannien
da hieß es dann die haben ja auch schon
bei 117 haben sie den griff gekriegt und
das war ein grund warum man damals
gesagt hatte deutschland kein problem
sein und es kam so dass wir in
deutschland in die anzahl 7 problem
hatten eine dritte welle trotz sozusagen
diese also dieser vergleich ist nämlich
sehr schwierig ja man kann sich dann
gewissermaßen inspirieren lassen aber
nur vereinfachten zu sagen aber die
schaffen sie auch so so einfach ist die
situation leider nicht jetzt haben sie
gerade schon die kritik aufgemacht
sondern haben quasi den axel springer
verlag jetzt mal muss man sagen es sind
viele publikationen abgewatscht kann ich
das mal so zusammenfassen darf aber ist
es tatsächlich nur schuld der medien
oder ist es halt auch tatsächlich ein
fehlendes wissen schafft verständnis in
der bevölkerung oder das wurde ihnen
jetzt auch schon vorgeworfen dass die
art und weise wie man sich selber auf
social media jetzt präsentiert und und
dort in die debatte eingreifen dass es
dann halt aufgegriffen wird von medien
und dementsprechend darauf verarbeitet
es ist wahrscheinlich eine kombination
von beidem also ich es ist extrem
schwierig warnungen zu tätigen auf basis
von prognosen ich glaube das ist die die
die die schwierige situation in der
türkei war im gegensatz zu sagen wir
viola prise man nicht einmal hermann
anderen modellieren die die einfach nur
die wahrheit abbilden wollen ich glaube
das lka hat einfach diese extrem
schwierige verantwortung dass sie durch
das was sie sagen die bevölkerung
beeinflusst und deswegen deswegen sind
es indessen nicht nur professionelle
modellieren die haben müssen auch immer
versuchen die bevölkerung zu lenken und
das ist eigentlich total medien hören ja
trotzdem hat das lka sohn also ist das
genau
und vielleicht müssten die medien also
in dem fall was die medien hätten tun
können ist schauen ob es andere was
andere modellierer sagen vielleicht
sagen geht es exakt das könnte bis zu
1000 seien andere modellierer sagen aber
es wird er so im bereich von 52 300
liegen dann wird es eher dann wird es
klar dass das lka nicht die wahrheit
propagiert sondern dass sie auch nur
eine gewisse einschätzung haben
und vielleicht ein szenario das so
gerechnet ist dass die bevölkerung
realisiert dass die lage ernst ist und
man höre da hat die aufforderung zu mehr
skepsis gegenüber den aussagen des
robert-koch-instituts durchaus ist es
hilfreich wenn man das robert koch
institut mit mit mit skepsis betrachtet
das sind da sind viele gute leute die da
arbeiten aber sie sind sozusagen nicht
unabhängige wissenschaftler und und
haben eine gewisse gewisses korsett
indem sie in dieses agiert und deswegen
ist es sehr wichtig genau dass man dass
man alles was das ok sagt noch mal
hinterfragt und sich überlegt was sagen
denn wissenschaftler dazu ist aber
grundsätzlich nicht falsch was er gesagt
hat das bmz 7 zu einer dritten welle
führen dass wir müssen uns wieder merken
dass das ja das stimmt
wir müssen unbedingt wie schlimm war das
eigentlich das ist okay so eine prognose
gefällt hat also haben wir irgendwas
gemacht was wir nicht getan hätten wenn
es rk ii gesagt hätte wir hätten eine
inzidenz von 200 gibt die vorwürfe der
panikmache der angstmache ist man kann
beobachten dass er dass die diskussion
in die richtung geht von sie glauben das
nicht mehr weil immer es kommt immer
neue horrorszenarios also da kann man ja
durchaus fragezeichen dran machen ob das
was bringt wenn man immer wieder warnt
und es kommt dann doch nicht so schlimm
das stimmt natürlich aber es ist
deswegen sage ich auch diese dieses
holzschnittartigen modell das war aus
meiner sicht wirklich wirklich ein
fehler das hat der differenzierte
kommuniziert werden müssen
aber prinzipiell ist es so dass kein
also ob es auf diese sozusagen das okay
sagt das voraus und das tritt nicht ein
die die handlungen die wir daraus
gezogen haben
die die politik getroffen hat die waren
richtig und wir haben trotzdem eine
dritte welle gab um trotzdem jetzt sehr
viele tote es heißt weniger hätten wir
gar auf keinen fall reagieren sollen
das ist das ist im prinzip ich ich
glaube es ist ziemlich schwierig leute
zu finden modell ihre und wissenschaft
zu finden die sagen wir hätten zu hat
jetzt reagiert in der dritten welle
wir sollten eigentlich weiterhin
versuchen und das ist natürlich
unabhängig von der modellierung jetzt
aber wir sollten weiterhin für
suchen die zahlen so schnell wie möglich
zu drücken weil immer noch zu viele
leute sterben
naja es gibt ja auch die steppen die
sagen es wurde nicht früh genug auf die
modellierer gehört wenn wir jetzt mal
gucken in die zukunft wir haben heute
die gute nachricht bekommen manche
kreise können wieder langsam auf machen
wir können wieder in hotels wir können
wieder in gaststätten zumindest im
außenbereich gehen was sind denn ihre
prognosen für den sommer geht es
überhaupt das haben sie gerade gesagt
also wenn man schon vier wochen nach
vorne modelliert ist es schon fast ein
glücksspiel können sie lesen aber mal
gucken also es hat mir so ich würde mich
nicht trauen numerische vorhersagen also
stellen einfach weil also ich hab ich
hatte nie weiter vorhergesagt jetzt vier
wochen einfach weiß dazu unsicher wird
und was man aber sagen kann ist dass die
impfungen auf jeden fall positiven
effekt haben denn der wird immer stärker
werden was außerdem passiert es die
saisonalität ist kleiner faktor aber die
wird jetzt noch mal auch durchbrechen
was dazukommt ist dass wir auch viel
draußen sein können das ist spricht ganz
viel dafür dass der sommer dass wir
immer mehr lockerungen ermöglicht können
immer mehr öffnen können
das einzige das einzige was noch
passieren könnte aber das wird er von
herbst relevant ist wenn weitere
besorgniserregende varianten auftauchen
die sich auch in deutschland durchsetzen
das ist eine große unsicherheit das weiß
man nie im voraus und das ist zum
beispiel bei dieser neuen indischen
variante b 16 117 2 sodass das wir grad
in einem bereich sind wo es erste
hinweise darauf gibt dass die
übertragbarer sein könnte es aber noch
nicht gesichert ist und deswegen sich
viele experten noch unsicher sind
inwiefern man so eine ungewisse so ein
gewisses risiko kommunizieren kann
und das heißt ich kann nicht sagen dass
nicht dass diese variante nicht
übertragbar sein wird und uns gewisse
einschränkungen wieder auf erzwingen
wird also ist das wichtig ist einfach
dass man sich vorstellt wir werden auch
im sommer nicht völlig normal leben
können wie vor mehr vor zwei jahren zum
beispiel einfach weil wir keine
herdenimmunität haben werden dafür
müssen wir bei dem jetzigen virus circa
85 prozent der bevölkerung impfen und
das werden wir vermutlich nicht
erreichen bis in den sommer
das heißt gewisse massnahmen werden
immer noch nötig sein aber es sind viel
viel weniger maßnahmen als wir im moment
haben und das ist sozusagen also ich
glaube wir können dann schon ganz großen
teil von dem was wir in fitnessstudios
zum beispiel könnten mit hygiene
maßnahmen wieder aufgemacht werden im
sommer bin ich mir relativ sicher
und dass es gibt extrem viel grund zur
hoffnung aber wir müssen uns bewusst
sein dass das immer noch passieren kann
dass das irgendetwas unvorhergesehen ist
das aktuelle ist ist möglich sagt auch
hier vorfahrt gerade kann es sein dass
das durch eine mutation zu einer vierten
welle kommt in naher zukunft dass wir
unruhig den oder die zuschauer in es
kann passieren aber es ist nichts was
wir nicht unter kontrolle kriegen
könnten also gerade mit den impfungen
wird es so sein die impfung werden auch
gegen zb diese neue indische variante
werden die impfung auch funktionieren
das geht halt immer darum welcher teil
ist noch nicht geimpft und vielleicht
ein kleiner teil kann schwach erkrankten
nicht sehr stark an den neuen varianten
dann geht es so ein bisschen weiter über
die zeit aber sagen wir eine vierte
welle könnte passieren und das ist aber
nicht unbedingt eine vierte welle wie
die dritte welle ist könnte einfach
sagen wenn wir die zahlen muss dann auch
sagen wir eine instanz von zehn oder
fünf gedrückt haben dass das dann zu
einem kleinen wäldchen kommt und dann
ist eben wieder die frage reagieren wir
auf diese kleine welle oder warten wir
erst wieder dass es hoch kommt und das
kann jederzeit wieder passieren dass die
effekte sind immer wieder die gleichen
dass das ist es nicht so dass das virus
jetzt einmal durch die bevölkerung durch
gelaufen ist und dass wir alle immun
sind das ist einfach nicht der fall ist
die bevölkerung die entscheidet durch
ihre maßnahmen durch ihr verhalten ob
wir weiterhin der dritte oder vierte
welle bekommen oder nicht
das nehmen wir mit in diesem montagabend
vielen dank herr römer für ihre
einschätzungen und auch für die
kritische betrachtung der wissenschafts
lage das ganze ist eben ein schwieriges
thema das haben wir heute wieder gesehen
weil es so viele unbekannte varianten
gibt dann geht für die einordnung ich
danke euch für eure fragen und fürs nach
bohren und eure kommentare und natürlich
wissen wir wie immer alle verlobten all
eure freunde machen dass er gerne und
ich sage bis zum nächsten mal bis zum
nächsten live streamen macht's gut
tschüss